bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur tv fil 78 aujourd'hui 16
avril 2015 dans l'actualité yvelinoise
des subventions en nette diminution pour
les associations de saint cyr l'école et
c'est l'amicale laïque qui s'inquiètent
après avoir perturbé le conseil
municipal fin mars une nouvelle
mobilisation a eu lieu hier soir 4e
édition des rencontres de l'autonomie à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des ateliers
qui viennent de se tenir aujourd'hui et
puis 63 ans dont 50 de carrière reza
deghati photographe d'origine iranienne
est l'invité d'une soirée exceptionnelle
à l'ugc de montigny le bretonneux
vendredi un rendez-vous à l'initiative
de l'union régionale photographique du
sud-ouest de l'île de france son
président elle nous en dira plus en
plateau tout à l'heure de fait divers
pour débuter cette édition à un plaisir
tout d'abord hier soir des voitures de
police de la bac ont reçu des jets de
pierres dans le quartier du val hibou
une trentaine de personnes en est à
l'origine quatre jeunes de 18 à 19 ans
ont été interpellés et placés en garde à
vue et puis attrape un peu plus tôt dans
la journée de mercredi des coups de feu
ont été entendus au square albert camus
un suspect a été interpellé après avoir
pris la fuite l'armé n'a pas été
retrouvée sur lui mais à terre et des
cartouches de 12 mm à saint cyr l'école
les adhérents de l'amicale laïque et du
sca au se sont une nouvelle fois
mobilisé ces deux associations voix pour
l'année à venir leurs subventions de la
part de la mairie en nette diminution
ces dernières parle de fermeture de quoi
inquiéter lors quelques 3000 adhérents
un sujet et de mélanie poker elodie mois
elle tente une dernière fois de se faire
entendre en février deux associations
saint cyrienne l'amicale laïque et le
club athlétique comme les sports
apprenait que leurs subventions
municipales seraient réduites l'argument
avancé par la municipalité
enfin par la majorité municipale
consiste à dire que en fait ils sont
obligés de faire un certain nombre
d'économies beaucoup d'économie du fait
en réalité de la politique
gouvernementale c'est comme ça que c'est
présenté en ce sens que les
collectivités locales c'est un secret
pour personne actuellement on voit leurs
dotations d'état diminuer
considérablement
l'amicale laïque regroupe 1700 licencier
54 salariés le seao lui à plus de 1300
adhérents et 28 employés une situation
les obligeant à avoir une administration
la perte de cette subvention amènerait
un manque de 100000 euros pour l'amicale
laïque la première solution c'est que
nous fermions tout simplement c'est à
dire qu'on dise où l'association faute
de pouvoir assurer effectivement le
financement nécessaire la seconde
solution consisterait à
faire en gros globalement ce que la
municipalité semble ce côté c'est à dire
un
ajustez totalement non eux
nos contraintes budgétaires et notre
budget assez à ces risques là si on fait
ça en fait ça signifiera que d'une part
nous serons contraints de fermer toutes
les activités par trop déficitaire ce
mercredi soir en conseil municipal les
associations ont obtenu un répit
leurs subventions sont garantis jusqu'à
la fin du mois d'août une motion dans ce
sens a été voté à l'unanimité
autre conseil municipal aux autres
villas plaisir mercredi en fin d'après
midi lors d'une séance exceptionnelle la
fermeture de l'école camille claudel a
été est définitivement entériné les
parents s'étaient mobilisés en mars le
l'ambiance était plutôt télé plutôt
électrique avec les représentants de la
municipalité la fermeture a été décidée
afin de permettre le reclassement des
enseignants le nombre d'élèves de cette
école était devenue trop faible 44
seulement répartis sur deux classes
autre sujet 4e édition des rencontres de
l'autonomie c'était aujourd'hui dernier
jour de l'opération toujours pilotée par
la structure saint-quentinoise gérondi
cap après un colloque mardi sur les
difficultés d'accompagnement au
quotidien à des ateliers étaient
proposés dans les locaux de gérer
handicap à magny les hameaux le point
sur cette problématique du
vieillissement de la population sa prise
en charge avec le reportage de yolaine
thorez et d'élodie moine un peu
d'exercice tous les jours pour améliorer
sa condition physique c'est le message
que tente de faire passer l'éducateur
sportif ce matin dans le cadre des
rencontres de l'autonomie il apprend et
ces personnes âgées ou en situation de
handicap et quelques exercices à faire
seul chez soi est toujours en adoptant
la bonne posture même maintenant dans la
pratique sportive c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on n'insiste pas on retrouve
beaucoup de cours collectifs et dans les
cours collectifs malheureusement n'a pas
le temps de corriger les personnes dont
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de défauts
dans la posture est ce qui entraîne plus
tard les problèmes donc effectivement
des problèmes qui s'accumulent avec les
problèmes de la vieillesse mais pas
marcher plus de deux heures par jour
faire des étirements régulièrement le
coach en profite pour prodiguer de bons
conseils je suis venu pour un petit peu
nous sortir un peu d'isolement
notre vie habituel et puis aussi
le thème l'atelier m'intéresser au
niveau de la santé active j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs que ça faisait bien travaillé
tous tous les organes du corps le coeur
le souffle des étirements je trouvais
très intéressant je vais me tenir le
plus longtemps possible bien et puis
j'ai par tous les moyens je sais de
faire le maximum quoi d'autres ateliers
étaient proposés tout au long de la
journée pour ces quatrièmes rencontres
de l'autonomie un rendez vous que vous
pourrez retrouver l'année prochaine
le plan de déplacement inter entreprises
obligatoire pour les sociétés de 500
salariés est une des mesures du plan de
protection de l'atmosphère en ile de
france pour aider les entreprises à le
mettre en place et le développer elle la
cci de versailles et la communauté
d'agglomération propose régulièrement
des ateliers d'information sur saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs secteurs
sont concernés de trappes d'elancourt
encore de montigny et de guyancourt
30000 à 40000 salariés sont directement
impactés pour les entreprises le plus
important c'est de comment faire
remonter leurs besoins il aura tenté
surtout les nécessités des salariés par
rapport au transport en commun donc
comment rendre plus adapté le transport
en commun aux besoins des salariés c'est
ça et donc plus elles sont réunies
le message arrive plus facilement aux
autorités en charge des transports il
est vrai que l'attractivité les
transports en commun et d'un des piliers
des yeux mais il ya aussi toutes
les autres formes de mobilité comme le
covoiturage le vélo la marche à pied
également toute la gestion
des flots des véhicules et
las la sécurité routière à l'éco
conduite sur 50 ans qui sont dans les pv
yeux une trentaine 30 à 40 entreprises
qui sont associées aux différents pv
yeux parce que sur saint quentin en
yvelines il y a cinq et des yeux qui
sont impulsées par la communauté
d'agglomération qui est notre partenaire
avant de passer à l'entretien de cette
édition cette information concernant la
verrière les élus de la majorité
s'opposent à la fermeture la du centre
de protection maternelle et infantile
qui serait à l'étude par le conseil
départemental pour la ville cette
structure destinée aux enfants de moins
de 6 ans répond à une demande toujours
aussi forte et sa disparition ne serait
lié qu'à des réductions de coûts de
fonctionnement et une motion a été votée
en ce sens lors du dernier conseil
municipal nous parlons culture
photographie à présent avec l'invité de
cette édition du 16 avril claude chose
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
le président de l'union photographique
du sud-ouest de l'île de france vous
êtes à l'origine de la venue de résa
célèbre photographe est d'origine
iranienne reza deghati reporter
photographe de renommée internationale
qui va donc participer à une rencontre
débat à l'ugc ciné cité de montigny
demain vendredi 17 avril 19h30 il vous a
fallu beaucoup de temps pour le
convaincre je crois oui effectivement je
travaille sur ce projet depuis deux ans
ça a été beaucoup de négociations avec
son agence de presse qu'il représente
sarah qui s'occupe plus particulièrement
de lui à comment vous dire à uvrer et au
bout de deux ans nous avons réussi à
obtenir ciblé cette interview et je suis
je dois dire que je suis ravi parce que
rza c'est quand même un photographe qui
qui me touche profondément et qui me
touchent fortement je vais dire plutôt
parce que si vous voulez son travail
était présume hanister trade et beaucoup
de sensibilité dans sa classe la
personne à je vais avoir quelques-unes
des photographies qu'il a réalisé
également c'est un militant résa né en
1952 premières photos 14 ans à 22 ans il
est arrêté emprisonné pour militantisme
politique militantisme artistique contre
le régime du chah trois ans de torture
de détention 81 il choisit l'exil il a
fait de la photo une véritable arme en
fait tout à fait oui et souvenez vous je
me permettrai de rappeler à ce que vous
venez de dire c'est que en 2001 il a
photographié deux jours restant avant
son assassinat le commandant massoud et
deux jours après celui ci était quand
vous dire assassinés cette photo pour
moi représentait quelque chose
d'important cible et où on voit la
générosité tout ce que tout ce que tout
ce qui est français tous qui transpire
pardon dans sa photographie qu'est ce
qui vous différencie tellement une photo
de ré là d'une photo d'un autre et bien
si vous laissez ce côté humaniste c'est
ce côté je dirais toutes ces photos qui
touche notre coeur si vous voulez qu'ils
qui nous sensibilise tout à l'heure j'ai
vu que vous avez montré la jeune fille
simuler la petite jeune fille il ya
aussi steve mccurry café une photo dans
ce dans ce style là tu sais donc que
cette photographe américain et quand
vous revoyez si vous voulez la photo de
cinéma curie on voit si vous voulez
cette petite fille qui est très jeune et
qui qui nous touche cibler ce regard
nous pénètre complètement donc voilà
c'est pas un simple photographia venons
message derrière ces il a un oeil
humaniste généreux il est à l'écouté des
personnes vous savez qu'il a fondé
beaucoup de dauger dans une géo gm pour
justement si vous voulez commander faire
travailler des jeunes sur l'information
et il fait beaucoup de choses dans ce
sens là il le fait généreusement quoi
faire des révolutions des catastrophes
il était au liban dans les années 80
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
impressionné sur sur son travail outil
dédié c'est particulièrement important
qu'il soit là demain s'il ya un cliché
un moment de gaieté cette image c'est le
commandant massoud quelque part qui
était un homme aussi dans son regard on
voit cette générosité malheureusement il
a été assassiné de deux jours après vous
avez tout tout son travail qu'il a fait
aussi pour dans le cadre effectivement
d'une marque de café de je ne citerai
pas mais sur les planteurs de café dans
le amérique du sud quitte aussi quand
même extraordinaire et puis tu es toutes
ces images que vous avez montré entre
autres cibles et de cette petite fille
qui en algérie qu autour d'un mausolée
je sais pas si vous voulez on parle
beaucoup de photos contemporaines mais
moins quand je vois ces images cible et
ça me touche au plus profond de moi et
j'espère que d'après ce que je sais pas
ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rencontrer à la direction générale des
postes et c'est un homme d'une très
grande générosité qui vous fait partager
sa passion et sachez que si vous voulez
aujourd'hui ses rangs sept ans fan
absolu vous allez recevoir demain ce jeu
je dirais que passer je suis fan de
plusieurs autres photographes mais ça
fait partie des photographes que j'aime
bien donc voilà pour qui j'ai de deux
l'estiment de l'attention et que je suis
très heureux de le recevoir comment va
se dérouler cette conférence débat qui
est ouverte à tous demain et c'est
gratuit en plus à celle du g7 était de
50 ans renseignements pratiques bien sûr
qui s'affiche pour ne pas manquer ce
rendez-vous comment ça doit se dérouler
alors je te dire que si nous faisons
cette conférence je dois remercier aussi
quand même michel laugier qui nous a
ouvert les portes qu'il fallait si vous
voulez le marc kravetz aussi qui nous a
prêté une salle sur le direct lens est
aussi je dois le je le remercie aussi la
communauté d'agglomération ciboulette
c'est grâce à à ces gens là cible et
qu'on a pu obtenir pour parfaire un
événement à la mesure du personnage
ciblées qui permettra quand même a plu
presque 500 personnes de pouvoir venir
assister à cette conférence ce sera un
échange aussi du travail
il va d'abord présenté cibler son
travail il va le commenter parce que
alors il parait t'il qu'il est très
bavard c'est pire que moi et après il y
aura une séance de questions réponses où
il répondra ci voulait à toutes les
questions avec votre collectif l'union
régionale photographique du reste d'un
collectif c'est pas un collectif s'est
produit alors l'association c'est radio
présente aussi avant la longue qui
dépend de qui est rattachée à la
fédération photographique de france qui
regroupe environ 500 photos club à
travers toute la france
dix mille adhérents et dans l'union
régionale du sud ouest ile de france
nous sommes 23 clubs photos et nous
sommes au delà des 700 727 130 adhérents
et l'objectif c'est d'organiser ce genre
de rendez vous étant mais voilà il
rencontre d'autres photographes tu vois
là c'est pour moi ça se casse ciblés
dans la formation parce que rencontrer
d'autres photographes et les écouter ça
permet aux gens s'ils voulaient de de
comprendre la photographic n'est pas
seulement d'appuyer sur le bouton
cartier bresson à des des phrases qui
disait que c'est l'alignement de l'oeil
du cerveau et du coeur si vous voulez
donc ces voix là mais la photographie
cible et il faut que ça dégage une
émotion sinon ça c'est pas c'est pas
très intéressant quel regard vous avez
sur les photos aujourd'hui que tout le
monde peut faire avec son téléphone
portable c'est resté vous savez je
dirais une chose qui est très simple le
stylo ne fait pas écrivain c'est pas
parce que vous avez un très bel appareil
photo que vous pouvez faire et que vous
allez faire des choses merveilleuses
c'est votre oeil c'est votre regard mais
je crois que dans tout ce que l'on fait
mais il ya des choses qui sont qui sont
bien moi j'ai ouvert de nouvelles
perspectives c'est vrai ça c'est à dire
que votre smartphone où il avait tout le
temps avec vous bien vous voyez quelque
chose tout à l'heure vous voyez jeu en
venant vous voir j'ai rencontré dans une
rue de versailles la statue de la toon
du nom la réplique qu'il était sur un
camion et s'est tassée avec ses deux
enfants artemis et aphrodite s'ils
voulaient c'était quelque part à ces
assises d'heyrieux ristic de voir la
toon qui se promènent sur le sur le
plateau d'un camion voilà c'est ça et
j'avais pas mon appareil photo mais
j'avais mon téléphone n'avait pu saisir
cet instant le mot d'ordre pour vous
c'est créer de l'émotion de louer ces
classes de l'émotion si vous laissez pas
le volume qui fait de catherine bresson
disait encore je vais je les cités comme
un fait une très bonne faute aux parents
ils disaient 3 voilà et pourtant ça a
été un grand monsieur de la photographie
mais ce que je peux dire si vous laisser
aussi rajouter c'est que nous sommes pas
un autre premier coup d'essai puisqu'en
2007 nous avions organisé la première
biennale d'art photographique de 51 en
yvelines nous avions reçu willy ronis
avec ses photos couleur et gérard
vandystadt avec tout ça tout ça série de
photos sur le sport nous avons aussi
fait une exposition sur esprit des lieux
s'ils voulaient donc je dois dire
qu'avec la ville de montigné et la
communauté d'agglomération nous avons
nous travaillons de concert et nous
arrivons à monter des événements si vous
voulez qu'ils sont qui sont qui j'espère
aps les eaux à la population de saint
quentin en yvelines enfin ce n'est pas
terminé cet entretien je vous propose
d'écouter notre question du jour
aujourd'hui nous sommes allez vous
rencontrer pour vous demander ce qui
pourrait ce qui vous émeut tout
simplement dans une photographie vos
réponses
me c'est quand même le naturel ce que
j'aime pas trop c'est la faute aux
préparer
j'aime bien la photo prise à
l'improviste c'est ça qui me alors ça me
serait c'est ce que ça représente et
puis c'est la beauté basse et la
perfection de la chaussure nos
graphistes pas vraiment la photographie
en elle même mais la chose photographies
qui ont peut-être un événement
historique marquant qui est qui révèle
ces par un vrai moment émouvant dans
l'histoire des couleurs naturelles quoi
un rouge et un beau versé à faire sortir
la photo quand on voit bien l'objet
principal où la personne quand tu as une
belle luminosité après y'a pas de ya pas
de choses particulières on va dire si
ici après l'émotion qu'on peut avoir sur
une photo je sais pas c'est pas une psy
quelqu'un qui pleure ou je sais pas quoi
ou un un psy comme suit alors un beau
paysage c'est surtout ça qui est simple
comme pour tous les arts chacun à son
niveau en fonction de ses perceptions de
son vécu aussi pour vous c'est quoi une
belle photo mais pour moi c'est une
photo une belle photo gd paye c'est
quelque chose qui va me toucher qui va
me provoque une émotion qui va me
permettre de rêver qui va me transporter
voilà il ya quelqu'un qui a dit dans
votre reportage qu'effectivement c'était
l'émotion vous savez que la photo soit
en couleur ou en noir et blanc mais je
crois que s'il voulait peu importe
qu'elle soit en couleur en noir et dans
lequel se la pète en argentique ou
numérique si peu importe c'est ce que
dégage la photo c'est je présume que
vous même vous en faites comme tout le
monde eh bien c'est ce que vous allez
ressentir quand vous allez au revoir il
faut savoir quand même qu'une photo
c'est une part de voûte de vous même à
un instant donné que vous vous fixez sur
une sur un capteur ou sur une pellicule
voilà merci d'être venu nous parler de
photographies et surtout n'oubliez pas
demain ce rendez vous exceptionnel avec
le photo journaliste humaniste reza
vendredi à 19h30 à l'ugc est skywest
pour ceux qui aiment la photo et ceux
qui veulent en savoir un petit peu plus
découvrir aussi tout le travail qu'il a
mené personnage très intéressant à
découvrir pour échanger avec lol merci
d'être venus en plateau lui aussi est
artiste jean michel wilmotte architecte
il a piloté la réhabilitation de
l'hôpital royal de versailles en
bâtisseur dans l'ombre du roi-soleil
l'inauguration de ce chantier l'un des
plus importants menés dans un coeur de
ville en france dernièrement vient
d'avoir lieu cet après midi 4 et du
gâteau et william bell
l'hôpital richaud renaît de ses cendres
à versailles après six ans de chantier
cet ancien hôpital abandonné dans les
années 90 abrite aujourd'hui plus de 300
logements dont 91 logements sociaux des
commerces une crèche un espace culturel
et un jardin ouvert sur la ville à la
manoeuvre l'architecte
internationalement connu jean michel
wilmotte dans chaque projet il y à une
aventure dit il mais là c'était un roman
la première fois pardon je suis venu il
y avait un tas de pierres et peu près de
deux mètres ici qui finalement était
tous les gravats qui est tombé et puis
toutes les colonnes qui est tombé au sol
que les jeunes qui squattaient le
bâtiment avait fait tomber c'est un jeu
amusant je faisais ton médical dont on
avait un gros j'ai une photo magnifique
d'ailleurs avec un énorme tas de gravats
qui était à cet endroit là à l'hôpital
richaud a débuté sa construction à la
fin du xviiie siècle une construction
entrecoupé de pauses dans le courant du
xxème siècle il est progressivement
abandonné au profit du nouvel hôpital
mignot transformé en squat le bâtiment a
subi trois incendies dont le dernier en
2009 aujourd'hui même on peut dire qu'il
est peut-être plus beau et plus
compréhensible qu'il ne l'a jamais été
parce que il a bénéficié par la force
des circonstances d'une restauration
d'envergure c'est un bâtiment qui est
immense comme 900 m par exemple de
cornish 500 portes et fenêtres tout a
été tout a dû être refait en particulier
menuiserie on a refait toutes les
toitures ya 20 tonnes de plomb c'est
également un bâtiment ouvert sur la
ville avec notamment un jardin public
d'un hectare c'est une aventure
magnifique parce que deux hectares
bloqué face à la gare dans le tracé
naturel de la ville d'un seul coup on
redonne cette transparence cette
circulation pour les eaux les riverains
pour les personnes qui travaillent à
versailles qui vivent à versailles ou et
puis on en redonnant un jardin espace
public avec cinq traversées à la 5
passage pour accéder dans ce lieu donc
ça c'est c'est une aventure si vous
dessine une belle aventure parce que
c'est un rêve qui devient réalité je dis
souvent c'est notre mini palais royal
ici maintenant c'est qu'on peut
librement circuler à l'intérieur on y
tenait énormément à ce que ça soit pas
un enclos dans la ville oui c'était le
risque un enclos entre guillemets pour
personnes ayant de très très gros moyens
il avait un risque fort une dizaine
d'architectes a travaillé sur ce projet
de réhabilitation qui aura d'autres
demandes et six années de travail
pour conclure ce journal un tout autre
univers c'était et hier mercredi à la
verrière parents et enfants pouvaient
venir et s'essayer au jardinage à la
maison de quartier orly-parc une après
midi consacrée à la plantation de
légumes de fleurs l'occasion pour les
enfants de découvrir les techniques du
jardinage william l la tomate on a dit
qu'elle s'entendait bien avec le chou et
avec la salade donc on peut la mettre
ici très bien chou radis carottes choux
tomates ses légumes les enfants les
connaissent bien dans leur assiette mais
aujourd'hui les jardiniers se sont eux
cet après midi consacrée au jardinage à
la maison de quartier dans l'eee parc à
la verrière est l'occasion pour eux
d'apprendre mais aussi de découvrir la
nature alors
la bagarre va l'attraper
délicatement
voilà tu me poses très bien daniel l'a
effectivement les pieds de tomates par
exemple tout à l'heure et il
ils ont pas reconnu ce que c'était parce
que effectivement sait pas on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas savoir ce que c'est
si on n'a jamais vu un pied de tomate
après les avoir plantés pour revenir les
arroser jusqu'à la récolte c'est vrai
que la plupart des habitants n'ont pas
de jardin donc en fait c'est l'occasion
de découvrir
un peu là les techniques de jardinage et
puis deux pour les enfants de découvrir
comment poussent les fruits et légumes
voilà et puis dodo de les apprécier
d'une autre manière aussi puisque quand
quand on leur fait déguster des légumes
qu'ils ont fait pousser eux-mêmes ils
sont très contents de les manger c'est
le cas d'israël à tout en appartement
bien d'or le jardinage pour elle c'est
l'occasion de s'y adonner on a planté
des salades des radis des choux des
thomas des pieds tomates et quoi encore
des carottes fêtons la plainte et on a
planté plein de légumes j'aime beaucoup
et jardiner mais ils n'ont pas
l'habitude non plus de travailler la
terre comme ça donc effectivement quand
il voit les magasins assez tôt du bol
des beaux fruits ils savent pas d'où ça
vient et et là bas et du coup comment on
arrive à vraiment à une tomate savent
pas que ça ça pousse comme ça comme un
petit arbre maintenant il ne manque plus
qu'un peu d'eau et beaucoup de patience
rendez vous dans quelques semaines pour
la première dégustation
prochain journal demain vendredi
l'actualité du jour l'essentiel de la
semaine à la présentation catherine
mulato il sera notamment question des
portes ouvertes de l'aérodrome de saint
cyr un rendez vous dimanche est
programmé pour des baptêmes de l'air des
expositions des conférences
l'un des organisateurs viendra en parler
en plateau pour le journal donc tout de
suite sur télé file file echo
l'hebdomadaire dédié à l'économie et aux
entreprises avec florane parfait
excellente soirée